- [Voiceover] In the last
video, we talked about
the meaning of current,
and current is defined to
be the movement of charge,
amount of charge per second.
We looked at a copper wire
where electrons are carrying the current,
and we looked also at a salt solution
where both positive and negative ions
are carrying the current
across this imaginary boundary
where we keep track of how
many charges are moving.
So now, next we need to talk about
how do we define a positive current?
What does a positive current mean?
So, I'm gonna move this up a little bit.
And we're gonna get to something
that causes some confusion.
But, we'll try to clear it up here.
The positive sign, this is
a convention that we use.
The positive sign for current
is the direction that
positive charges move.
So, that's the direction...
this is the direction a
positive sodium ion moves.
This is the direction a
negative chlorine ion moves,
When I assign a positive
direction to the current,
the overall positive direction
is gonna be in this direction.
That's plus current. Plus current.
Alright, and the same thing
actually holds for a wire.
If I draw, let's go back
and draw my wire again.
If I draw my copper wire,
and inside there we know that
all these little electrons,
all the electrons are
moving in that direction.
So q- is moving in that direction.
And when I assign a direction
for the arrow for a current,
the current arrow points this way.
Plus current.
So for instance, if I had
10 electrons per second
that were moving in this direction here,
I would say the current is
plus 10 charges per second
in this direction.
And ask yourself:
If it's always electrons
carrying a current,
why on Earth do we point
the arrow in the other way?
And that actually goes
back, way back in history,
to out friend Ben Franklin.
Ben Franklin is the person who said,
who basically made a decision
that said the charge on
an electron is minus.
Now, when he made that decision,
nobody knew there was such
a thing as an electron.
So Ben Franklin.
And that was in the year 1747.
Ben Franklin's a person
who assigned plus and minus
as being the two types
of charge that existed.
And when he did that he had no idea.
Nobody had any idea that
there was such a thing
as an electron.
Electron was discovered by a
physicist named J. J. Thomson,
In the year 1897.
That was when the electron was discovered.
And believe it or not, if
we do the subtraction here,
look at this, it's 150 years.
For 150 years of electric research,
we were able to figure out
a lot of really good things,
assigning current
going in the opposite direction
of electrons in metal.
And it's all okay. It's all okay.
One of the questions that's
often asked by new students,
is why don't we switch it around
so the current points this way?
Why don't we assign an electron,
why don't we make current go this way?
So, why didn't we just switch it around?
Well, we had a 150 years of experience,
and now we've actually had another 120,
since the discovery of the electron.
And we've managed to get by with this.
We have not chosen to do it.
One of the reasons we
don't do it is because
it would basically, it
would be a big mess.
Imagine if for instance,
say in the United States
we decided, Oh, driving on
the right side of the street
is the wrong side of the street.
We want to all drive on the left.
Imagine the chaos that would cause.
Now, before we made the change,
everybody managed to
get where we were going,
and after the change, everybody
would get there going,
but the change over would
be just so, so costly.
And the same thing with electricity.
We can do perfectly well
talking about current going the direction
of a positive charge,
just like we did here
with the positive sodium
going in this direction.
This is actually how electricity
is conducted in your body.
So, it's not uncommon to have
positive charge moving around.
That's the definition of
current in a nutshell.
We put a boundary across,
and you watch the charges going through,
in either direction, which
ever direction they do,
and you count up and you get q per second.
That's current.